- I'm so confused,
are you breaking up with me,
or, are you not breaking up with me?
- [Woman In Green] Oh, look,
he's crying, he's crying.
- Don't none of you look at them tears
and think that (beep) is funny.
- Well, I'm not a baby.
- Are you not a baby?
- [Man In Black] I'm not a baby.
- Who pee pee'd their self?
(mellow music)
- Carvel thanks you for coming.
The first order a business,
I'm sure y'all heard that Twigs
got pulled out the river this morning.
Now it ain't no secret,
he and Carvel grew up
in the hood together.
Listen up,
Carvel about to say some words.
(Carvel sobbing)
Okay you know what?
Don't none of you look at them tears
and think that (beep) is funny.
Because it takes a big (beep) man
to cry in front of his crew.
Go ahead Carvel.
- Y'all know Twigs was my boy.
Back in the day
we used to pretend the
sofa cushions was a fort.
- Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
- And we used to pretend
that the floor was more lava (sobs).
- Okay, you know what though?
There ain't nothing funny about that.
Of course, this man is crying
because he in Twigs was
kids together, okay?
Him and his best friends
forever and (beep).
Go ahead Carvel.
- We used to play Care Bear.
- Mm-hmm.
- Twig and I would spend the
good part of an afternoon
trying to figure out
which Care Bear we was.
- Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, I wish one of y'all (beep)
would just start laughing.
Cause y'all know, you
think this (beep) is funny,
Carvel over here blubbering
and talking about Care Bears.
But you know what?
But you (stifles laughter)...
Those some manly tears, okay?
Those some manly ass tears
right there that you looking at.
Go ahead Carvel.
- And then, and then, and
then, and then, and then...
(Carvel sobbing)
- (laughs) I'm sorry man.
That was a weird ass sneeze
I just did right there.
God damn it, can the brother get some
(beep) Claritin up in here?
Go ahead Carvel.
- Twig always fancied himself Share Bear.
(gang member grunting)
I always thought of myself
at more of a Funshine bear.
- Okay, okay, all you (beep)
need to respect that right there, okay?
Y'all need to listen to Funshine...
(laughs) I'm sorry.
(gang member laughing)
I'm sorry man.
You were Funshine bear man, I'm sorry,
that is some funny (beep).
(loud gunshot)
- All right, let's go sell some crack.
- Give me a roll.
- Which one you want?
- Just give me both of them man.
- Okay.
- I decide which one I
want when I want to eat it.
- Maybe you want some
of these vegetables too?
- Nah, nah.
- Just saying man.
The nutrients is good for
maintaining energy levels.
- I know what the (beep)
a vegetable is man.
Don't tell me what a vegetable is man.
Hey, I'm a grown ass man.
All right?
- Mm-hmm, yep, I'm sorry.
This three bean salad is the bomb though.
- Oh snap, they got three
bean salad up in there?
- Mm-hmm.
- I ain't even see that.
- You want some of mine?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Open the hanger.
- What you doing?
Nah, you don't do that,
you don't feed me like a kid man.
I'm a grown ass man.
- Okay, yes you are.
You got some schmootz right here.
- Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Get off my face (beep).
You never touch a grown man's face.
- Yeah, that's right, I'm sorry, okay?
You are a grown ass--
- Hey, hey, hey.
I don't need you to pat my
back, I'm a grown ass man.
What you doing?
I know you are grown,
I don't wanna hear it
anymore about grown ass man.
- Well, that's what I am.
- I don't want to hear it.
- You treating me like a kid.
- This is not place for this kind of,
don't start acting up in here.
- Because you making me angry.
- Okay, then I need you
to breathe a little bit,
can you breathe?
- Don't tell me how to breathe.
- I want a mother (beep)
inside voice up in this bitch,
don't be getting loud up
around these white people.
You treat me a baby, but I'm not a baby.
- Are you not a baby?
- I'm not a baby.
- Who pee pee'd their self?
Did you pee pee yourself?
- I pee pee'd.
Just a little bit.
- Okay, let's go in the
bathroom and change, okay?
- I don't wanna change.
- We gotta change--
- Get your hands off of me.
- Is that how we behave?
- Yes.
- [Mum] Is that how we behave?
- Stupid bitch.
(mum gasping)
(hand slapping)
- Oh, oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry,
you a grown ass man, you a grown ass man.
Who's a grown ass man?
You a grown ass man, okay?
- I am.
- You a grown ass man.
You know what grown ass men do?
You go to the bathroom
and change your pants
when you got pee pee, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
Okay, let's go.
Let's go, all right?
Excuse me everybody.
I'm sorry,
but my son got that
Benjamin Button's disease,
he's four.
- Well, four and three quarters.
- I saw in the news today,
talking about the violence
in foreign countries,
talking about all the
savagery up in the world.
But they ain't never
talk about south central,
ain't never talk about what
happened to my brother.
Now he's gone.
And now I ain't got no brother.
- Yo dog.
(melancholic music)
I'll be your brother.
- Really?
- Absolutely dog.
You're gonna need somebody to lean on.
You can't just be walking around here
with this emptiness in your heart man,
an emptiness that can only
be filled by a brother.
- Okay.
- Brothers man?
- Brothers.
Come on man, get in there dog.
Tuck it, tuck it, tuck it.
- Brothers man.
Come here man,
why the (beep) do you keep
following me around man?
Why don't you go home
and stay outta my room?
Don't mess with my models.
I'm about to get a wedgie up
in this (beep) right here.
- What?
Hey, Hey, get the (beep) off me man.
- Hey.
- Hey, you don't give
a grown man a wedgie.
(beep) I'm 34 years old.
I got grandchildren.
- So what do you wanna do tonight?
I was thinking maybe we could
meet up with Amy and Brad,
and before that we could go to Angelo's,
and before that we could just go behind--
- Meagan.
I have something to say.
I had to say it in person,
because it's super important.
- Okay.
- I know this is sudden,
but I've been thinking
about this for a while
and I know this is something
that needs to happen.
I'm breaking up with you.
- Cool, love it, totally fine with that.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I thought...
I was really worried that
you were gonna be mad.
- Mad?
Oh my God, are you kidding me?
No, of course I'm not mad,
people grow apart, it
happens, it's part of life.
No, I'm totally fine,
love it, love it, love it.
- We had a good run.
(melancholic music)
Don't be a stranger, yeah.
- Can I just...
Can I ask why?
- Why?
- Yeah, what evs, I'm
doing some work on myself
and trying to grow as a person.
- Cool, cool.
- I'd really appreciate to know why.
- Yeah.
Okay, yeah.
I think that you're kind
of a controlling person.
- Thank you, thank you for that.
That's nice, thank you that.
- Cool, no problem, yeah.
- So you know what your problem is Andre?
- What?
- You keep tabs on people.
Every little thing somebody does,
you have to keep a tab of it.
- Wait, I can't tell
if you're angry or not.
- I'm not.
I'm totally not angry.
- Oh.
- No, I'm excited, it's good.
It's just you said your piece,
and I just think that I
deserve the human decency
to say my piece.
- Right, right.
- Is that not okay?
- No, no, no.
No, of course, of course.
- You're a controlling
manipulative person,
everyone says it.
- I don't think that I am.
- Yes you are Andre,
yes you (beep) are.
- Okay, now you sound pretty angry.
- I'm not angry.
I'm not angry, I'm fine.
I love it, I love that
you came to my house
and you broke up with me in my space.
And I'm gonna think about
that every time I'm here,
that's great, that is so perfect for me.
It's the best thing that ever (mumbles).
- Where else was I supposed to do it?
'Cause you won't come to my house.
- Oh, there he is, the
puppet master is back.
- But I'm not the puppet master.
- Why are you doing this to me?
- It's true, you won't come to my house,
you said my apartment looks like
two rats just (beep)
in it every (beep) day.
- Oh right, thank you for that.
I'm a bitch, thank you, thank you.
- No, I didn't say bitch.
- So which is, am I evil or am I a bitch?
- No, no, you're not evil Meagan.
- Well then why are you punishing me?
- I'm not punishing you.
- Oh, you broke up with me
and I'm not supposed to feel punished?
Who thinks like that?
- (yells) I don't know.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, okay Meagan?
I guess I didn't think it through.
- Well, it's too late now, we're done.
- No, it's not too late,
Meagan, Meagan seriously.
I had a feeling that I thought was true,
and clearly it wasn't true.
- I'm so confused.
Wait, are you breaking up with me,
or, are you not breaking up with me?
- Meagan, I'm not breaking up with you.
- Okay cool, so what do
you wanna do tonight?
I wanna hang out with Amy and Brad,
but maybe before that
we can go to Angelo's.
(tense music)
- What just happened?
- Look at this mess.
It makes me sick.
- There's no way to stop
this kind of insane violence.
It seems like no matter what we do
some innocent fool is always
gonna get slaughtered,
and we're always gonna
be playing catch up.
We're never gonna find
the guy that did this.
- Tell that to his widow.
(mellow music)
- And we're always going
to be playing catch up,
we're never gonna find
the guy that did this.
(widow sobbing)
- [Woman In Green] Oh, go, look at that.
- What?
That's amazing.
- He's so good at this.
- Amazing.
- [Woman In Green] I
know, look at your points.
- Oh, oh.
- Look at that, nice, nice.
- Dude, you have absolutely
mastered this game.
- Well, since Sheila left,
I've been spending a lot of time.
- [Guest] Here we go.
- Playing the game.
- You're doing really good.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- That's why we're here man,
to help you get over her,
and check out this
awesome new game you have.
- Yay.
- I left something in another room,
excuse me everyone.
(game chiming)
- Oh, he still has the sensors on.
- Oh look.
- Is that him in his room?
- Yeah, you can see him, that's funny.
What is he doing?
Is he on his knees, did
he drop to his knee?
- Oh no.
No, he's probably looking for...
- No look, he's crying, he's crying.
Oh no.
- He's just...
- No, no he's shattering.
He's shattering.
- He's shaking.
- [Woman In Green] Is he fetal?
Yeah, he curled up, look at that.
He's fetal.
- Hey Craig, buddy,
you all right up there?
- [Craig] Oh yeah Bob,
I'm coming right out.
- Okay.
Hey man, you all right?
- Yes, yeah, oh yeah, yeah.
It's just my sinuses are acting up.
Yeah, yeah, I was just
thinking about Sheila
and you know what?
I am totally over her.
- Awesome.
Hey, let's get this party started.
- Sure, yeah.
Oh.
I forgot to get rid of
this picture of Sheila.
Excuse me.
Hey, maybe leave this sensors
so one of us can play.
- Oh he's dancing, he's
dancing with the photo.
He's doing this about, is he kissing it?
- Guys?
- [Woman In Green] I
think he's kissing it.
- You know what?
I'm gonna gonna turn this
off, 'cause we don't need to.
- You change it and you die.
He's undoing his buckle, look at this.
His pants are coming off,
his pants are coming off.
Oh God.
- [Bob] Yeah.
- [Woman In Green] No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
- Okay, that's happening?
- Oh no, no, no.
Gosh, is he?
He's totally on the bed.
- Yeah.
- He's totally flat on the bed.
- [Bob] Oh, maybe he's
shaking a can of hair spray.
- [Woman In Green] Oh God.
- Gross (winces).
- Oh gross.
- We shouldn't be.
Okay.
- Is he reaching down for his foot?
- [Bob] I don't know.
- That's his foot, isn't it?
Is that his foot?
- [Bob] And coming back, coming back.
- I am sorry everybody.
Would you like me to make some snacks?
- Wash your hands first.
(game chiming)
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh I want you, but I don't need you ♪